you know when you look at something that
looks hard that was probably easy you
know and I had this firm belief which I
still believe that people are basically
good don't take no for an answer when
when people out there are giving you
advice and saying no this will never
work if you're passionate about
something and you work hard then I think
you'll be successful code does change
the world and you know it can change
people's lives if somebody does
something nice for you
wouldn't it be nice in this world if we
could actually start recognizing that I
think we've lost a lot of that in
America it's something that here in
Europe we're a lot more familiar with
there are no entrepreneurs out there
that are more hard-working and
innovative than the small business I
didn't sit down and say hey I'm gonna be
innovative today and if I say that you
should treat people with the benefit of
the doubt it's because I believe in that
is a way of life he's a French born
American entrepreneur and philanthropist
he's the founder of eBay where he also
served as chairman from 1998 to 2015 he
has an estimated net worth of 7.2
billion dollars he's Pierre Omidyar and
here's my take on his top ten rules for
success when you look at the
accomplishments of accomplished people
and you say boy that must have been
really hard you know when you look at
something that looks hard
that was probably easy and conversely
when you look at something that looks
easy that was probably hard and so
you're never gonna know which is which
until you actually go and do it so just
go and do it
try learn from it you you know you'll
fail at some things that's a learning
experience that you need so that you can
take that on to the next experience and
don't let people who you may respect and
who you believe know what they're
talking about don't let them tell you it
can't be done because often they will
tell you it can't be done and it's just
cuz they don't have the courage to try
it I started sort of this just with the
idea of let's bring the power of
interactive technology you know the web
to ordinary people and you know and I
had this firm belief which I still
believe that
people are basically good and as I said
if you if you treat them well and if you
treat them with with you know benefit of
the doubt you're not gonna be
disappointed and in the modern world
despite you know we're bombarded with
negative images all the time about how
bad the world is how dangerous the world
it is and it is true there are some
dangerous things going on and there are
some bad actors out there but the vast
majority of people out there are just
good decent honest people there's
something about an entrepreneur that is
somewhat sort of anti-establishment
somewhat is respectful of the previous
generation and although that can great
people the wrong way a little bit and
it's a really important element actually
you need to be passionate about what you
want to work on and don't take no for an
answer when when people out there are
giving you advice and saying no this
will never work I mean yeah you look at
eBay the idea that that the 1995 that
you could create something over the
internet which is this brand new thing
that nobody you know was really using at
the time except for scientists and
academics and and it would be a place
where strangers can actually do business
with one another can actually like
exchange merchandise from firms for
money without ever meeting you know and
the notion that people can actually buy
in some cars over the Internet that's
crazy
right it's totally crazy so in fact the
lots and lots of people told me that was
crazy and I didn't you know I have to
say I didn't have this vision oh it's
gonna take over the world it's gonna be
this fantastic thing overnight I didn't
have that kind of delusion either by but
I didn't say you know what there's
something there's something worth trying
here it's not it's not crazy I say that
you know you should pursue your passion
if you're passionate about something and
you work hard then I think you'll be
successful if you if you start a
business because you think you're gonna
make a lot of money at it then you
probably won't be successful because
that's the wrong reason to start a
business you have to really believe in
what you're doing be passionate enough
about it so that you will put in the
hours and the hard work that it takes to
actually succeed there and then then
you'll be successful I
no I've heard the story that the first
line of code that you wrote was an
apartment in Campbell that's right not
too far from us down the street that's
right I mean did you have any idea you
know you wrote this you put it out on
the Internet yeah you didn't sort of do
it thinking hey I'm gonna build an 83
billion dollar business no of course
it's not at all about at all really I
mean it was just this um as I said I as
a software engineer I wanted to write
some tools that I thought could be
useful to ordinary ordinary people
regular people I had a day job started
as a nights and weekends project and
it's amazing of course now you know we
all understand code does change the
world and and you know it can change
people's lives
but I think what makes eBay unique
despite the fact that they're many sort
of now there are more marketplace
businesses out there yet we are really
have always been about people
it's always been about bringing tools to
ordinary people and giving them the
tools and the opportunities that they
need that they can use to then be
successful and to find success in their
own way so yeah the those early those
early weeks and months were crazy you
know so I remember one of the very first
items listed this was in 1995 in
September of 1995 one of the very first
items listed was a 1952 silver dawn
rolls-royce okay and and the seller and
I wish we could find a seller the seller
was amazing because he or she had done
this beautiful listing and so you know
you could put HTML in there the the
seller had created a server somewhere to
actually host photos back in those days
you know you had to actually only you
know run your own server to host photos
and actually had these beautiful listing
on there I looked at that and I said
this is incredible there is no way
anyone will ever buy a car on the
internet like that's just ridiculous
that'll never happen
of course now there's a car sold every
four minutes when I'm on a mobile device
I mean it's it's incredible it's totally
incredible
so who could have
imagine it is actually in February of 96
I came up with the idea of creating this
the feedback form and basically what
that was was to encourage people to give
each other feedback based on how did the
transaction go and and since I was
getting all these complaints I assumed
that it would be mostly negative that
you know it was a forum for people to
give each other negative feedback and so
so I wrote this little this little
letter to the community in feb 19 ounces
the feedback forum and I had basically
in it I said hey listen people are
basically good we all try to do a good
job we all try to do our best but
sometimes things don't work out it'd be
great you know let's give each other the
benefit of the doubt but if you're
having you know if you're having real
problems with somebody now there's a
feedback forum you know basically you
don't have to complain to me but there's
a feedback forum if if your complaint is
worthy of complaint then you should do
it publicly you know and complain in the
public forum but while you're at it also
think about giving praise where praise
is due if somebody does something nice
for you wouldn't it be nice in this
world if we could actually start
recognizing that and and you know this
give each other praise where praise is
due and you know we found that when you
give somebody the opportunity to give
praise to give positive feedback when
it's well-deserved people love to do
that it's very gratifying yourself to be
able to give praise to to somebody else
and
and so anyway so the feedback forum is
just a remarkable incredibly gratifying
testament to human nature and the
fundamental goodness of human nature but
then also from a business perspective it
was really the thing that allowed eBay
to succeed because it gave people a
chance a way to know that they could
actually trust the complete stranger
what I realized through the eBay
experience was that people are hungry
for personal communication and personal
relationships that they can build around
the shared area of interest and I
received hundreds of letters thousands
of letters from from eBay users that say
you know eBay is restored my faith in
humanity I've met my best friends on
eBay you know there have been people
that have been married that have met on
eBay I mean it it's it's a little bit
it's a little bit strange it's
definitely not the you know the majority
of the users but there's something
special going on there and I think what
it is is when you give people a forum in
which to communicate and communicate
around a shared area of interest no
matter you know what socioeconomic
classes they come from what
neighborhoods they come from or
geographies they realize that they're
human beings and they realized that they
can be a community together so what we
want to do with our philanthropy is to
just help people rediscover that in
especially in America I think we've lost
a lot of that in America something that
here in Europe we're a lot more familiar
with or a lot more comfortable with the
notion of an individual being a part of
the community and having a
responsibility to be a part of that
community in America through a very you
know a variety of reasons that I won't
go into here I have some thoughts on it
you know people have become isolated and
people are afraid to talk to their
neighbors sometimes but at the core
people do want to be part of a community
and all we have to do now is figure out
how to how to kind of rekindle that a
little bit and that's that's our mission
we've got you know I'm young I'm 33
years old my wife and I are 33 years old
we've got at least 50 good years ahead
of us to work on this and it's gonna be
a lifetime pursuit there are no
entrepreneurs out there that are more
hard-working and innovative than the
small business owner I mean like give me
a break so everybody is OK Silicon
Valley
these wonderful entrepreneurs but and of
course you know we all work really hard
in Silicon Valley here as well but it is
really hard to be to run a small
business and even though you know the
base growth was very fast in those early
days I learned some of some of the
difficulties myself as an individual
just having to deal with all that so
that for me is true entrepreneurship now
when people here in Silicon Valley also
do is we have this incredible sense of
vision of what's possible in the world
and I think to be a successful
entrepreneur you have to have also a
little bit of self delusion in your own
ability to make that happen I didn't sit
down and say hey I'm gonna be innovative
today I really it was really trying to
experiment with new tools and I'm a
software engineer so basically the
latest school's shiny toy at the time
was the web was interactivity and the
way I expressed my creativity was
through writing code fast-forward to
Labor Day weekend of 1995 i sat down at
my computer and started writing a script
a perl script to create a very basic
oxygen mechanism and
the code was really simple it just
allowed you to list an item for sale you
can have a title and a description in
this starting price and you could also
see a list of all the items that were
listed obviously that was important and
then you can bid on an item if you think
about a retail environment where people
are buying things in a retail
environment the retailer has a whole
bunch of control they choose the
products they design the store or the
catalog if they train the salespeople
they control the experience and if
there's a problem with a sale you know
with the salesperson they retrain and so
on and so forth at eBay our customers
experience is based on how one customer
interacts with another customer ok and
you can't control customer behavior so
the only thing you can do is have a
certain set of values that you encourage
people to adopt and the only way your
customers are going to adopt those
values is if they see that you're living
those values as well so when I say that
I believe people are basically good is
because I believe people are basically
good I mean it's not something that I
came up with for eBay and if I say that
you should treat people with a benefit
of the doubt it's because I believe in
that is a way of life and we have to do
it internally at eBay at the company as
well because if we don't then eventually
that seeps through and customers will
see that and that will harm our business
because you know we can't control
customer behavior so our business is
based on that thank you guys so much for
watching I made this video because more
teza dari Yanni asked me to so there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want me to
profile next leave me in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do I'd
also love to know which appears top ten
rules hit you the hardest meant the most
to you leave it in the comments and I'll
join in the discussion thank you so much
for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon